couple of weekends ago me and the boys  at a game Jam called ladum dare or  ludume this time around we made  something that we were actually really  happy with a puzzle game called  dichotomy a word that none of us had  ever heard of before in every dichotomy  level your goal is to reach the flag you  have 10 seconds to execute any kind of  maneuver you want in the sandbox before  your moves are played out in what we  call the real world the actual level  being the real world though it's full of  danger with various deadly tiles and  traps that make completing a level more  and more difficult as you progress  through the game Watch the full video  and play our game for free Link in  comments and now let me tell you a story